hey everyone davolo here and in today's
video we will delve into a pivotal point
that left fans on the edge of their
seats a section of story that revived
one of the most beloved characters in
the series the resurrection of Saturday
Gojo and the preparation for the final
Arc of Jujutsu Kaizen and this Dope
video we will retrace the exhilarating
events of how they managed to get our
man back along with the final moments or
what I at least consider to be the final
moments of the culling game How It Ends
the reason for its ending and the start
of the most climactic Showdown the
series has ever experienced this is is
like literally the moment we have all
been waiting for so if you are new
around here and want to watch content
just like this but for a multitude of
different series then hit that subscribe
button and if you want Mega Million
narabara to ever return the only way
it's physically possible is if you like
this video it's it's a weird glitch I
managed to find so push this video to 5K
like stare just before we do move
forwards though the Kings themselves big
raid Shadow Legends hit me up to let you
all know that they've just recently
dropped a brand new limited series
series called raid call of the Arbiter
it's free to watch and actually looks
super dope like I I truly wasn't
expecting it new episodes of this
limited series are out at 10 A.M Eastern
Standard Time every single Thursday
until the 20th of July as I said when I
first checked out the show I truly
wasn't expecting the level of detail
that had gone into each scene like say
on episode 7 where we watch nut on his
quest to prove himself like with my
videos sound effect placement is massive
as it brings in the atmosphere for
moments and this episode just excelled
in every field it was pristine andromion
with how Dynamic it was so if you
already have a favorite character check
out this new limited series as it
expands the already extensive lore
exploring the backstory for many of the
Champions you see in raid also if you do
already Jam raid as well you get the
chance to get artec one of the five new
characters from the show which have been
added as a playable legendary champion
for free all you gotta do is just log
into raid for seven days between now and
the 24th of July but if you haven't
started raid yet jump in by using my
link down in the description below or
scan my QR code on this screen to get
some insane bonuses like you get the one
and only epic Champion Drake From The
Lizard Man faction and other useful
things worth thirty dollars so once
again go and check out my link down in
the description below or scan the QR
code and thank you to raid Shadow
Legends for sponsoring this video but
either way sit back and relax as we
delve into Jujutsu Kaizen
so kicking things back off after the
sakona Revival part of this story and
standing there in the middle of the
football field after a mind-boggling 1
000 years yodazoo has finally reunited
with her love as we learned at the end
of the sukuna Revival part of the
culling game this long-awaited
confrontation takes place and the Heart
of the Sendai Colony more specifically
and assuming I'm correct for the old
Googles here this is most likely the
eurotic football stadium located in
Cindy's nanakita Park as the two
reincarnated Souls stand facing each
other it's clear that both yoduzu and
sukuna have the same thoughts on their
minds they are literally a killer couple
zacona the king of curses exudes
confidence firmly believing that goddess
who stand no chance against him with no
time to spear yodasu Springs into action
launching a blistering attack on sakona
but he effortlessly evades the strike
swiftly retaliating with the devastating
Kirk hold on this is a price twist in
store yodazoo never won to miss a chance
to lighten their mood playfully teases
sakona pulling a funny face to catch him
off guard sukuna's like primary goal
here is to obtain yodazoo's vessel as he
plans to eliminate megami's sister
sakumi and ultimately consume Megami
Soul by accomplishing these nefarious
Deeds sakuna aims to solidify his claim
as their most formidable and most
powerful entity in existence yodes who
expresses her curiosity about what
sakuna could offer her as she actually
emerges Victorious and a stunning twist
socona confidently assures Yoda zoo that
if she does emerge Victorious he will
grant her any wish that her heart
desires these Stakes have never been set
higher yoders who then like whether
mischievous Glenn to her eye playfully
suggests the idea of marrying sukuna
surprisingly sukona seems like adelian
phased by this unexpected proposal as if
it's happened a multitude of times
before or something with excitement
bubbling in her voice yoduzu exclaimed
that they've now made a promise yoduzu's
enthusiasm knows absolutely no bounds as
she excitedly envisions their future
together plotting the destruction of
three specific Villages yoruzu then
reveals her Twisted plan for their
wedding reception which includes
adorning the trees with the most
handsome men from Village it's fairly
evident that like yodazoo Harbor's
Sinister intentions and her excitement
Peaks as she mentions her favorite meal
which is monkey brains out of all things
honestly like this scene here has to be
some kind of reference to Indiana Jones
and the Temple of Doom the old monkey
brain thing just like instantly made me
think of that just has so many different
references to Great forms of different
art like the bath same with hiromi
hugoroma or Alman Hikari and is like his
entire underground fighting ring being a
direct reference to fight club by the
way as yodazoo continues delving into
the winning details she is abruptly
interrupted by the arrival of the Divine
dolls surprisingly yodazu
single-handedly takes down the onslaught
of the Divine dogs and realizes this
Akuna isn't even using his own technique
on her saguna advises yorazoo to utilize
her very own techniques as well but she
declines tsukuna stand in there Connor
plays various possibilities within his
mind he understands that in order to
sink Mega me soul deeper into the spear
he must first destroy his vessel's
sister it turns out that aside from
cursed holes he odeszu's construct and
can replicate any substance she is
familiar with through diligent practice
the seasoned sorcerer has mastered the
art of manipulating liquid metal
allowing her to change its shape and
volume automatically through cursed
energy control the armor that yodizu
wears is inspired by a fusion of various
evolutionary strands making it an
incredibly formidable weapon skipping
away though for a moment and
transporting ourselves back to the
hearing era we find yodazoo lost in deep
contemplation so in a similar aspect to
Ryu when it comes to Pure curse energy
output yodazoo was quite powerful and
one of the strongest Sorcerers of her
time however her curse energy
consumption rate posed quite a challenge
but then out of nowhere a rumor then
reached yaruzu's ears about a legendary
butterfly capable of Crossing vast seas
and guess what yodazu saw a glimmer of
hope in the efficiency and energy of
those tiny insects but her Newfound
Revelation didn't end there turns out
that these insects possess superhuman
strength capable of lifting objects
hundreds of times their own weight a
strength befitting a formidable sorcerer
like yodazoo through this yarazu soon
realized that her insect armor was the
Pinnacle of construction techniques
allowing her to recreate various
substances except for those special
grade cursed tools I kind of think of
her ability as just like the most jacked
out version of my xenon's construction
ability that she could possibly have or
the ability that she might have gotten
if say she wasn't actually a twin but
you know that's I guess another entire
video that someone could talk about
someday I ain't gonna be me continuing
onwards this unique combat style of
yoresus trendy tables on the notorious
Goku show the five void generals earning
her a place of respect in the fujiwara
clan back in the present yodasu
unleashes her hardened armor bursting up
through the air before landing their
powerful blow that connects to rexley
with the king of kursa's face yorazoo
determined to unravel sukuna's plans
boldly questions him about his
intentions regarding his Shrine
technique however the tide suddenly
turns asakuna unveils his devastating
tranquil deer technique a formidable
counter to any summoning and a shocking
twist to fate Yoda Zoo loses control
over her liquid metal now canoe realized
that the Tranquil deer has neutralized
and nullified her cursed energy within
the metal it's a game changer that
leaves you really and something we never
even see Omega me think about using to
make matters worse fate can be cruel and
in a single brutal moment sukuna strikes
yodasu with his Diva setting piercing
bull attack inflicting a deep agonizing
wound to her abdomen it's revealed that
zakona intentionally used the 10 Shadows
to keep the shukigami partially unstable
allowing for a larger effective range
without them falling apart both the
Tranquil deer and the piercing Bowl were
summoned using the original 10 Shadows
technique but the independent movement
was restricted resulting in reduced
overall movement however since akonas
immense cursed energy was reserved their
form remained stable despite enduring a
life-threatening wound himself theodosu
holds on like a champ and wants Akuna to
not underestimate her she tackles the
piercing ball grabbing its horns and
Landing a powerful blow to its head
yodasu notices that tsukunichigami only
moves in straight lines and in exchange
its power dramatically increases out of
nowhere though a swarm of bunny appear
blinding your vision and making it
almost impossible for yarozuna to track
down to Kona so Kona you know like being
the trickster that he is Hills Max
elephant downwards while he floats in
mid-air and a surprising Twist Again
yodasu transforms back into her original
form again looking like sakumi except
like the sakumi here just looks way more
jacked up and cooler than she did in the
past where she also becomes determined
to teach the Kona love suddenly a moment
of realization hits godzu though which
he wonders a sakona already knows about
love which begins to actually make her
mad man yodasu is actually one of the
most random characters which is cool but
like oh my Lord she's like Sheba from
house Paradise if you know her like in
some aspects with that super out there
personality anyway skipping away from
the current day and heading back to the
Golden Age of Jujutsu we see that in
mesmerizing Harvest ritual is taking
place some individuals in the crowd
can't help the question and why they're
offering prayers to a fierce a monster
like sakona little do they know these
folks belong to these Celestial Squad
the five boy generals who seem to have
conveniently forgotten sukuna's previous
atrocities against the esteemed fujiwara
Clan amidst the hustle and bustle a
helper approaches yodazu addressing her
as master and informing her about the
upcoming Harvest Festival damn he
honestly was a total Baddie man she
responds to the helper demanding that
they lower their voice and if that
wasn't enough she gets even more annoyed
when they help her has the audacity to
suggest that she puts on some clothes in
preparation for the festival like how
dare she got a zoo however manages to
find some form of excitement in the
festival as it promises to offer
delectable Chinese pastries to the gods
out of the blue yorozu then spotsy man
calmly sitting down also half naked she
approaches him with confidence and
straight up hugs him assuring him that
he's not alone in this world however
another meddlesome helper intervenes
urging yaruzu to step back undeterred
yonazu boldly declares that she'll take
the place of that man's Helper and
refuses to let him feel lonely yes my
friend it was love at first sight a once
only lifetime encounter that made
yoresu's heart Skippy bait yet this
wasn't the usual beat skip when it came
to love no this time as she proclaimed
her right to be with zakuna a slash
appeared on her body and she fell to the
ground finally proving that love does
indeed kill honestly what a turbulent
backstory and I wouldn't expect any less
from such an out there character like
what are you what are your thoughts all
on her right now the Ambitions are kind
of random to me like a little bit like
Shader I guess fast forward back to the
present now where the air is thicker
with skeptical tension as yorozu and
sakuna continued to engage in their
first battle yodazoo more determined
than ever to insukuna's existence
conjures up a sphere filled with
Darkness sukuna can't help you to notice
the peculiar Perfection of that sphere
okay so giggy this chick is absolutely
crazy but you go and give it one of the
most cracked abilities in the entire and
the entire story so far I don't even
know what this fear is considered in
regards to like her technique like is it
a maximum technique or is it just an
extension of a creation tick I don't
know but like for a moment and just
nerding out on this thank you to Reddit
jujut sushi for like being the big
brainery because I would have never
figured this out but a perfect circle is
a shape that has an infinite amount out
of points all at an equal distance from
a center this means that no matter what
angle of attack you come from your first
point of contact will always be a single
infinitesimally small point pressure is
like defined as a force acting on a
cross-section have you keep the pressure
the same but reduce the cross-section
size this means that any amount of force
acting upon an infinitely small area
will have infinite pressure januzu's
perfect sphere will technically destroy
anything it touches because it will be
an infinitesimally small point of first
Contact regardless of what angle you hit
it from anyway sending the ball forth
goduzu reveals that a true sphere is
thought to be impossible due to its lack
of contact area which generates infinite
pressure then bring your hands together
yorazoo attempts to unleash your domain
expansion threefold Affliction but as
she looks towards zakuna she's shocked
to see that he didn't even open his
domain as well so kuna being the
unbeatable chair that he is drops his
random wheel that he had and summons
another shikagami which just happens to
be the freaking strongest of them all
the eight-handled sword debut Divine
General maharaga instantly maharaga
thrusts her sword upwards obliterating
the perfectly formed sphere and her
domain with the others of having fallen
to the floor fatally wounded as well and
utterly gobsmacked sukuna smugly points
out that her energy and efficient curse
technique will always make the same fate
regardless of these substance she
constructs be it liquid metal or insect
armor sukuna and his eyes he has already
adapted to it ringing it and effective
against him lying there seemingly fading
away and with a smile on her face though
you'll just do others some final words
of Happiness before gifting something to
Daddy sacona flashing her into the
depths of Mega me though we see that as
he lays there curled up in a fatal
position some forms of light began to
break through so what do you think do
you think uh she gave something to
secuna that helped with like subduing
Mega me and making a full deeper into
the darkness or was it something that
like broke through and made that light
appear perhaps or was it lighter in
ethereum it was slowly set in the
clothes and it was just my incorrect
assumption on the same I anyway this
stage is now set for a brand new day of
Darkness as kinjaku not content with the
game's existing challenges decides to
add some new sick roles that will push
our new Sorcerers to their limits
kinjaku orders his loyal servant
colgaine to introduce a new rule that
bans any new players from joining the
game but man gets instantly denied as it
conflicts with another role either the
Shima kinjaku attempts to decipher the
motives behind tengen's decision to
place barriers all around Japan he
wonders if kingard's intention is to
suppress the curse outbreak by creating
purification barriers that enhance the
effectiveness of barrier techniques
there are four particular barriers that
hold great significance in this grand
scheme of tingans one such barrier
surrounds the Imperial Palace and the
other around the Tomb of the star the
third barrier is in the Kyoto yamakuni
Imperial Mausoleum and the final barrier
is situated at the sacred heater Holy
Mountain the foundation of this brutal
culling game rests upon the
awe-inspiring Bond barrier and even
better barrier than pure ones according
to Big Kenny this game has no true
Master more that he's forced tinken into
that position walking around like what
seems to me the inside of the heater
Mountain Shrine area or whatever their
um tinken head kinjaku comes up with all
sorts of possibilities including the
deactivation of the barriers he reveals
that if tinken deactivated the barriers
after the events of Shibuya the culling
game would have actually come to an end
all of his Sinister planes would go down
in vain however if tinken did follow
through with that it would cause the
underwing of 1 000 years of process and
endless Wars against different curses
Heaven revealed just how in control of
everything he is kinjaku once again
repeats to cocaine to prohibit the
entrance of any new players otherwise
he'll destroy the purification barriers
and Force the game to close this
literally causes the kogane to glitch
out allowing the rule to get added to
the game he also added another rule
which is that the game would end Earth
all players except migami fushiguro and
suguru ghetto are dead has kinshaku and
tinken the inventure 4 throughout the
area tingen questions the fact that if
he truly wanted to end the game why
don't he just remove the barriers like
he threatened but the reason for this is
because he actually needs those barriers
for tingen's eventual merger with the
Japanese population having made it to
the center of the barrier they encounter
the very embodiment of evil itself which
was most likely being held here for
safekeeping as it was inside like a
barrier so why let these guys are
playing this Sinister game of Robin
mummies and you know trying to ruin the
world and everything in a hallway at the
exact same time Maki and we we are
seeing disgusting things related to the
killing game and how killing sakuna and
kinjaku would make him win the game
which is just wrong only Mega and sekona
can physically win the game now which is
why I narratively say that the killing
game ends from here however they also
discussed zato and wonder if killing
sakona would be as hard as killing Gojo
a new flashback and back after sakona
sent like hanakurasu flying freaking
Miles She was luckily saved by Amaya and
cushioned from her fall and then like
the greatest Sorcerer of them all in my
opinion takaba stayed with her
throughout the rest of that battle to
keep her safe when she wakes up at the
hospital little later on she hears shoko
saying that she's definitely not in a
good condition to participate in the
game anymore Yoda asks her if she's able
to transform into another human form
three vessel like sakona Angel who
herself explains though that one of the
reasons she and the other sorcerers of
ancient times took hinjaku up on his
offer was because none of them knew how
to become cursed items after death this
fact Still Remains True to this very day
but the Fallen himself is completely
different in the scenario she also
explains that After experiencing death
once sukuna most likely stumbled on her
way to split his soul as a cursed item
which I weirdly kind of think is like a
horcrux from Harry Potter and how like
big baseball has sold seven times to
escape death either way henna also
reveals that her role will come to an
end once she dispels the seal on
Saturday Gojo outside the hospital now
Amai found himself consumed by
self-loathing as he constantly compared
himself to these stronger individuals he
beard his soul to itadori confessing
that he always carried a deep sense of
Shame and inferiority around others and
response aidadori opened up about the
unsettling emotions he experienced upon
meeting am I despite his eagerness to
change and fight alongside edudory and
my admitted to feeling a profound fear
knowing that Amaya had managed to save
Angel after sakuna sent to herlene
through some of the nearby buildings
Yuji thanks him as now they still
actually have some kind of chance and
this messed up situation this confuses
our like Jewish Japanese man because
from what he's heard Yuji had no way of
fighting without sakuna's strength bath
however Hellboy explains that just
recently he was informed that his body
is like a cursed object dipped and
sukuna's energy now he's gonna eat
anything to Pummel that creep and save
his mate what determined them ever Yuji
then returned to the hospital and
encountered due to Marquee and the other
sorcerers hoping to offer them some
suggestions on how to save migami choso
then presented him with a book brimming
with information about the prison Realms
dark secrets and tsukomo's meticulously
documented research on the soul which
before the battle in the kinjaku
extermination art she entrusted her to
show so so like that's how we ended up
getting it and stuff so don't get
confused on how like choso has this
hearing what not I'm pretty sure you he
knew she was going to die in that battle
and that's why she handed it over also
and mental hint has given to us on what
yuji's technique could consist of Joseph
says that it's fine if the siblings are
blank as long as they can go on living
as a part of the ug which begs the
question what happened to their siblings
did Yuji ate them like it's insinuating
throughout this part of the story I
don't know I don't know I'd love to do
her thoughts down in the comment section
below I'm pretty sure like I've
mentioned this beforehand in another
video but it's extremely interesting to
me by the way on the other side of the
room chilling up against the wall when
smoking a big old black Shoku just
thinks back on how Gojo promised he
wouldn't leave anyone alone back in the
day she used to be in love with one of
the duo but that could never happen and
now they're idiots all alone and they're
a bunch of monsters needing his help
please go Joe come back so with like
everyone still big chilling inside of
the hospital the warrior of the group is
deeply concerned about Gojo's state of
mind and rightfully so being trapped in
the present realm could actually mess
with one's head as time does not flow
within it however whatever is trapped
inside cannot die due to starvation or
old age kurusu knows the danger there
could be caused of the strongest
Sorcerer of their time turns out to be
crazed and starts killing everyone he
sees but Shoku has like her own
reservations here as everyone's talking
about unsealing Gojo she believes that
unsealing him in a confined space of the
hospital is a risky move like who knows
how large the explosion could be so to
fix his predicament a determines you due
to sorceress embark on a journey to
saitama prefecture specifically to the
koroko mines interestingly the Croco
mines is trading ground number four for
Jujutsu High revealing that they have
other similar like locations about but
what I find more interesting is that the
actual location of Kuroko in Japan is
located in Hokkaido so does that mean
that they've traveled up there and not
saitama or is this just like a mistake
on my Googling skills it's probably a
mistake of my Googling skills to be
honest I don't blame me boys I'm sorry
about that one either way as enumaki and
edadori how about up together behind
some makeshift barriers kurusu takes to
the skies soaring above and preparing to
unleash a curse technique like no other
the legendary Jacobs later kudosu takes
aim and with one salmon drinks the full
force of Jacob's Lair towards the prison
realm itself and the hope to finally
bring back Gojo with the brightness of a
nuclear blast could a Sue's technique
engulsed the prison realm but a shocking
Revelation unfolds before the eyes and
the entire realm disappears Into Thin
ear yes the prison realm an extremely
formidable presence if you ask me is now
nowhere to be found penicon chooses
everyone rushes towards the spot where
the round once stood only to be met with
dispersing dust utterly confused Yuji
looks over to the vessel and Hannah
tries to explain to him that it isn't
her fault like that he suspected earlier
Gojo might have just turned to evil and
Delight from Jacobs later could have
made him disappear amidst the chaos
kurosu's mind starts to wander
questioning whether Gojo as truly an
evil spirit bringing her back to reality
though an earthquake suddenly shakes the
entirety of the continent taking the
whole group by surprise back inside of
the barrier and also I'd say bikini
heroes in Tokyo calling in number one or
the ihe colony as its closest to where I
assume the hay day mountains are that's
if that's where sakuna's body was either
way like that's where they were last
seen as kinjaku is having a discussion
on the prison realm with a special
someone he reveals that currently the
prison realm is placed at the subduction
zone which is 8 000 meters below the
surface of the ocean and the deepest
part of the Japan trench and just if it
had an extra level of security he placed
extra curse spirits to act as senses
beneath layers of extra seals that he
created the reason he went to such
extreme lengths is because tengen told
him about the back of the prison realm
and this way he'd still be able to take
Gojo down using the environment he's
placed in that depth is a crushing 800
atmospheres of pressure like you'd
literally be vaporized if you were
naturally subject to that dip but well
goju is just uh he just he's built
completely and utterly differently as
all of a sudden he now appears staring
down looking absolutely magnificent in
asking hinjaku if he's ready to end
everything kinjaku tries to irritate the
greatest sorcerer to ever live that Gojo
tells the fame that he should be
choosing his words carefully as these
These are his final moments taken by
surprise himself though Gojo easily
manages to block a few random strikes
from the other body swapper taking his
new appearance and goju just states that
Megami has indeed changed from the last
time they saw each other so remember
back on like episode 1 or whatever it
was Winter couldn't mentioned that he'd
murt Gojo first once and for all when
he's finally revived well now with him
finally having swapped up his skin
scroney just mentions that it turned out
to be this Brat's body that he's now in
but either way nothing's changed after a
rumor shows up as well and her along
with the king of curses continue to
verbally abuse Gojo sukuna Reveals His
intentions on defeating the legendary
six eyes user but Gojo just calls him
pathetic a roommate witnessing this
whole situation gets mad and tries to
attack Gojo but in a fraction of a
second gets slammed with one punch
knocking into a wall and causing the
poor check to start fading from reality
standing in there and saying that the
two beasts are about to throw hand
kinjaku rushes towards sakuna urging him
to fulfill their promise hearing this
Lacuna as following orders Gojo deses
them some more but here's the catch Gojo
has got more than just a fading sukuna
on his mind at the moment that's the
chaos of battle strategies swollen in
his head hit initially into the barrier
to retrieve ghetto's body from kinjaku
Little did he expect this shocking twist
that awaited him sakuna joining forces
with kinjaku via a binding vowel
continuing with like Kenny's check
though Gojo asks for the current day and
after hearing that it's like nearing the
end of November proposes that the entire
battle takes place on December the 24th
hearing this kinjaku cracks up at the
Romanticism of that specific situation
and agrees these Stakes are extremely
high as goju finds himself under
ghetto's watchful gays questioning
whether Gojo truly believes he can
emerge Victorious from his epic battle
do we all remember back at the very
beginning of the series when Yuji had
asked Gojo as Kona is stronger than him
of course at the time Gojo stated that
it may be a tough fight if stickuna
regains all of his powers causing Yuji
to ask if he'd lose Gojo probably been
like slightly cocky to the newcomer had
replied that he had won and here just
like in the past and now Roger unveils
the truth stay team no before the two
strongest characters and the entire
verse face off we take into a roommate
delivering sakuna some fingers and
apologizing for not being able to locate
the final one so somehow a roommate
managed to survive that punch to the gut
that made her fade from reality for a
bit so kuna reveals that like the last
finger may already be in God's position
causing a roommate to get annoyed they
got you for a second time managed to
outdo her sakuna gets up and begins
eating The shinbotsu Mummy a cursed
mummy that in his eyes can compensate
for one finger's worth of cursed energy
the same thing kinjaku whose civil
discussion with cocaine the discussing
the killing game that still hasn't ended
cocaine reveals that there are a total
of 61 players that died by cursed
technique removal because they never
entered a colony wanting to know if they
feared death or take any life Co game
reveals that those 61 players simply
lacked into a shin after all once
hegoroma added his role they could have
avoided both of those scenarios he
realizes that the people of Japan have
convinced themselves they have no
control over their reality even when
their lives are tasering bring he knows
that not everyone has the courage to put
their own life at stake but if they're
forced to by someone else then have no
choice but to act however with no hope
of the present or future these pathetic
humans in his eyes are willing to die at
any time directing his speech towards
Tinker now he tells the thumb that he
despises those who never learn the
feeling of approaching their ideals one
step at a time what does Super sus
kinjaku we all know what you had to go
through with kaori and the fact that you
cherished every step is crazy bro either
way I think it's kind of safe to say
here that with no one else being able to
join the Cullen game it's ended yes it's
still active but cocaine is kind of
stuck in a leg lock and unable to
proceed further with adding people so
like what's the entire point the game's
now glitched it can't even continue we
know that the next step is for konjaco
to merge tank and worthy population of
Japan and when that happens the Cullen
game is truly finished at that point but
that could happen for all we know the
second to last chapter of the entire
series with gigo's current pace so here
in my eyes is where the coloring game
comes to an end as it leans perfectly to
what we go into from here watch my guys
if Giga isn't lying on this being the
last year of judicial Kaizen then this
next stuff has to be the final Arc for
sure he's probably lying but you know I
don't know how man can end this story in
the next 18 Champions with all of the
info that we need to know but I'm not
home here's the Holy Scripture so I'll
let him decide his face not me some
random old YouTuber bouncing back over
to our man Gojo where he's giving like a
few tests done himself after getting out
of the prison realm he points out that
there are only three of them left from
his class shoko also points out well one
isn't recovered yet and along with that
Gojo states that he thought in an army
was the type to survive no matter what
ajichi then steps in and apologizes
since he thinks that Gojo would have
preferred his death rather than an
armies jokingly asking if his opinion of
him is that low goju motivates EG and
asks him to stay sharp as he still has a
job for him to do after a while inner
roles in as he has something that he
needs to say to the group but Wayne
exactly subject to the secret meetings I
wonder what it could have possibly been
the scene then shifts over to Maymay
who's actually set up an entire live
stream pay-per-view to watch the Gojo
fight along with a full beating system
intertwined within it this woman just
breathes money like the fact that she
already earned Five Bell just from
selling pay-per-view broadcasts is
insanity either way in front of her Yuji
using a judo throw tosses kusakabe over
his shoulder and tells him that it is
enough for now randomly though echon
that kusakabe seems to have interchanged
his soul with Yuji and the belt that we
just saw was fought with the two and
opposing bodies which is like what does
this mean Yuji can switch bodies with
people or does it actually have
something to do with kusakarabe's true
technique there's just so much that we
don't understand in this section and
it's all for like a specific reason that
I'll actually get to in a moment a few
moments later we bounce over to the
original Duo of this series we Yuta and
enumakia have any yarn Judah explains to
him that he didn't tell Yuji how he lost
one of his arms as it shouldn't be his
burden to bear watch a new market is
just super chill about man like
completely understands the situation
when it to Yuji and like sakona and the
body swapping stuff and then not being
actually yuji's fault and it's shown
that him and knew that might even have
something set up for future battles
which is interesting I wonder what it
could possibly be as I wanted to explain
just before with Yuji but I had to wait
a moment and just explain the stuff
before it we seem to jump around all
over the place like we were on the what
19th of November and now suddenly we're
actually on the 24th of December but
they start with Gojo and that role model
was getting checked up after getting out
of the prison realm was that straight
after in November still or was that the
day before going away and it was getting
checkups before leaving a top one of
Shinjuku skyscrapers though kenjaka
reveals that he will take care of the
rest of the participants of the game
while uramae and sakona fight Gojo urume
who's just like annoyed with kinjaku
asks him to stay away from Mr Kona but
he's in no hurry to leave as if he did
leave sakuna's side any earlier than now
then Gojo could have just wiped him off
in map if this battle goes well though
then the other defense was just used too
high will be if you to Maki and akari
take the opportunity to cut down sakuna
while he's weakened if that fails King
Jacob was left to do what he pleases and
is willing to take that risk now just
before fighting all of the Jiu Jitsu
Sorcerers are seen lacking together
discussing how to encourage Gojo in
their battle as to be honest they've
never had to do it before strolling up
from behind them though and rolling down
some steps Gojo accompanied by Gramps in
otahime all with looks of determination
get ready for battle with everyone
around failing his Aura Yugi creates a
Sensei wholeheartedly and lets him know
that no one can get close because his
techniques in the way go to get surprise
and after a moment ends up laughing or
telling his boy to give it to him which
is absolutely crazy man with Yuji
rolling up and slapping his Sensei on
the back we get to see goju's allies all
roaching for him and Pat him on the bed
just before he faces one of the toughest
battles in the history of Jujutsu Kaizen
walking through a skyscraper with Gojo a
duty knows that it feels like ages since
he was last here when in all reality
it's only just over a month now one
thing to know what the prison realm felt
like which is crazy that they hadn't
asked him beforehand because you'll
explain each year every prison realm was
like when you're mad busy with work that
it flashes in an entire week however the
feeling is so draining that you'll never
want to experience it again a few
moments later God you inquires about the
people on the basement of shibuya's
metro station where the chaos started if
we've been like super specific that's
where Gojo came across chosu Hanami and
jogo even though Gojo fought them for a
very short period of time at least
remnants of Gojo's curse energy that
made the curse Spirits avoid the floor
entirely this man's so strong his
residuals even scarecur spreads away
which is just one of the most broken
things I've ever heard it's also
connected to Shibuya and the inventory
Arc where it was classified that Gojo's
birth changed the Jiu-Jitsu World in
general dual cursed Spirit started
appearing as more wounded to hiding just
because of Gojo's appearance she's just
like wow ajichi also reveals that the
people who were affected by a 0.2 second
domain are all fine and that those that
were affected returned to normal walking
up behind grams and udahime atop the
roof now Gojo and ajichi arrive as the
Day of Reckoning has begun elsewhere a
roommate asks what time they fight was
going to take place to which sakuna
reveals that they didn't even specify a
time but say if it is able to feel
Gojo's Aura emanating in his Direction
before we get into the final fight we
actually need to learn about Gojo and
ganji a little bit you know like what
what's going to go on there sometime
throughout the month that previously
just passed us gakuganji exposed himself
to Gojo and told him that he killed
principal Yaga but it was weird as goju
kind of just acted calm and blamed
himself for being sealed as it caused
all kinds of things to happen including
megami's body being taken over by sakona
and the deaths of other sorcerers as
they continue their conversation though
gakuganji reveals what principal Yaga
said to him on how to create cursed
corpses and hearing him reveal this Gojo
figures that Gramps didn't tell anyone
about it it's revealed that Panda's
secret is a special great case and that
if it was before Gojo was sealed then he
would have notified someone proving that
a change definitely happened within Goku
ganchi then and another crazy reveal a
charm there's someone effort be Gojo
kinjaku sukuna or someone else to get
all of the Jutsu higher ups allowing
Gojo to go as far to say that it would
have been bitter if Gramps was running
HQ now back in the hallway though and
before they made it to the roof atishi
confronted Gojo on why he wanted him to
construct the bear area turning back and
looking at his close friend goju tells
him that it's because he trusts him more
than anyone else slamming his hands
together on the ground now in
preparation for his barrier ajichi just
thinks on how he's someone who always
fled no no someone who didn't even have
the courage to flee and was given me
courage to run by a friend despite
everything ajichi braces himself and
knows that he must live up to Gojo's
expectations either that or die trying
in front of the two and while using a
curse technique called solo forbidden
Arena it's explained that any Sorcerer
of her choosing including urhime herself
will have their curse energy reserves
and output temporarily enhanced as long
as they remain within a specific range
to excel at Jiu Jitsu is to excel at
subtraction the degree to which a
sorcerer can emit Cadence movements and
other elements that relates to their
curse techniques determines their skill
and usahime leaves nothing out words
gestures dance music elevating a simple
technique to that of a virtual boosts
Effectiveness by 120 percent odahime's
curse technique allows her to boast a
chosen sorcerer's curse energy and as
Gojo himself also begins chanting to
edu's own technique nine ropes polarized
light Crow and declaration between front
and back it's revealed that just like
our girl Gojo has also never left
anything out and with a combination of
the Trio's cursed energy shoots four as
200 Hollow purple as Gojo's ability
blasts forth skona manages to take
notice of it and throws up his hands
trying to block the entire attack with
buildings all around him exploding due
to Holo purple zakuna's defenses are
undoubtedly breached as the building he
was standing on is completely demolished
causing it to fall to the ground below
as he smokes slowly begins to fade it's
evident that due to wichita's barrier
Spooner actually misread goji's first
move even though he knew where he was he
didn't sense the insane energy output
until the very last moment bursting
through the smoke though sukuna with one
less hand saw him managed to tank the
first leaving the true battle between
history and today's strongest Sorcerers
to continue so begging for the blast
sakuna and arume were located at the
Shinjuku Center which is around four to
five kilometers away from the Shibuya
building Gojo was at having strolled
across that distance in a matter of a
milliseconds Gojo he probably teleported
like let's be straight he probably
straight up teleported goju sets the
record straight and tells the king of
curses that he is the Challenger here
and that's it ladies and gentlemen Gojo
is indeed him and we are about to
witness one of the greatest fights in
any manga of all time the entirety of
Jujutsu Kaizen has built up to this
moment and it's one that we can like you
you cannot afford to miss it so like
once this fight does come to an end
which I think is like the fifth chapter
now I will actually end up covering the
whole thing but obviously I have to wait
till it's done and I'd imagine that
possibly there's other stuff that's
gonna happen in between it so I might
even make other videos on other stuff in
between this here though does bring the
video to an end for the Gojo Revival
part of like I guess the Cullen game and
then the start of the final Saga
whatever you want to call it I'm not
really too fast that's crazy when you
like think about it and like a Time
perspective how it's only been like 20
days or something that Gojo was stuck in
the box but in her chapter releasing
time it's been around like 1 200 days
since the man was free which is
absolutely crazy the current fight is
like truly fantastic though and I
recommend anyone to read it weekly it's
Gigi like hardly ever seems to miss and
it has so many people decisive on who
they actually think is currently winning
and I'd love to know on who you think is
currently winning either way if you are
still here then do subscribe and push
this video to 5K likes so that I know
you want more I'm going to be dropping a
video covering the whole culling game
coming up next week which is a
continuation on the actual series and
stuff so that comes after the perfect
preparation Arc and it's like finally
you know it comes to an email and
everything so be sure to look forward to
there also shout out to raid again for
sponsoring this video make sure you go
down and check out my link in the
description below or scan the QR code on
screen to get a bunch of amazing dope
goodies in game by the way for now it's
been your professional editioner at
diavolo and I will see you wall and hey
Bert bye